hello and welcome to the 2022 season of
the st louis corporate chess league my
name is alex kirford a financial advisor
captain of team edward jones and the
founder of the st louis corporate chess
league i want to extend a special
welcome to the new companies that are
joining our competition this year and
say welcome back to the companies that
are returning from years in the past
chess has continued to grow in
popularity in the united states and
around the world and it's been no
different here in st louis as we
continue to see the corporate chess
league expand that means greater
competition stronger companies that are
going to be playing as well as more
networking opportunities we have some
very exciting things planned for the
corporate chess league for this year i'm
excited to get to share that with all of
you and have fun participating in chess
this game that we all love
the board is back in play 2022
spring season starts now
that is right everybody it is time for
the new season of the corporate chess
league uh huge thanks to alex and mike
for that wonderful intro uh now my name
is caleb denby and i will be your host
here tonight we've got a lot of exciting
matchups a lot of fun going on in this
new season our first event here is going
to be virtual and you may notice i'm not
in my normal studio
like in the last year i'm coming to you
from my home tonight this time not
because of kovid but because it is very
very icy outside and so we're we're
going from home today but super happy
that i can still bring this broadcast to
you guys and i think we're going to have
uh a lot of fun
so without further ado let me pop over
here uh to our main view and really
quickly let me just say we have darty
and enterprise
back from the previous season along with
ascension bayer edward jones and color
art who i believe is a new addition to
the corporate chess league all competing
here tonight trying to get some regular
season points some grand prix points so
they can qualify for the uh coveted
play-off positions where they will be
battling out to get their name on that
corporate chess league board that that
mike was showing off there in the intro
so i do believe games are about to
get underway if they haven't already so
to start off with i want to take a look
at
the enterprise versus doherty
match up here we have kamikaze knight
returning for enterprise
along with moneyballin kendalum big
daddy jazz and nirvan b dardy i'm seeing
some some familiar names as well we've
got c cell 0603 we have des rats we have
i love legos too
ina de keva
and mike
schwimweg
so let's see if i can go ahead and
follow some of these players
all right we've got kamikaze knight with
his game already underway against cello
603
let me see if i can pull up a moneyball
in here as well
um and although those six teams appear
on our standings as i'm scrolling
through it looks like we only have uh
four
full teams competing here tonight and
that is enterprise and doherty uh in our
first match up going on at the same time
is actually ascension and bayer so be on
the lookout for for those two teams as
well and i'm not totally sure what this
means for color arts and uh and edward
jones but not fielding full teams i
didn't get didn't get the uh
the
uh
the full story on that one uh and yeah
hello thank you everyone for joining me
in the chat you see that ghost set yet i
have a nice ghost set here behind me but
it's not about go tonight it's about the
chess so without further ado let's see
if i can figure out what's going on in
these games kamikaze knight leading the
way leading the way for enterprise we
have an open sicilian
looks like a bishop c4 dragon uh f3
queen d2 and this rookie eight move i'm
not sure if it's this exact position
but uh a friend of mine actually
struggled against this rookie eight move
it's sort of a really cagey move uh in
in the dragon definitely want to be
aware of
um h4 by by white is following the
normal plans so yeah just h4 g4
and knight h5 does not make a lot of
sense so i think this is the pretty
classic yugoslav attack white expanding
on the king side playing for mate and
black felt like they were under so much
pressure that they already sacrificed a
piece so
looking good for kamikaze knight then
after bishop h5 we see the classic
exchange sacrifice
um opening up the the g file here
and i don't think black is going to be
able to keep everything together as we
see bishop h6 coming in
uh the queen will come in to follow with
checkmate so looking very very good for
kamikaze knight right off the bat and we
already have our first result a draw by
repetition repetition between
moneyballin and desrats looks like
moneyballin
uh was trying to
play for uh the win with the pieces on
the seventh and desrat was having none
of it just goes straight directly for
this repetition so our first result
there first result
yeah uh kamikaze knight i believe this
is john boyer um
definitely one of the strongest board
ones in the entire league
leading the way for enterprise
let's continue on down the list though
we've got kendalum on board three for
enterprise let's see if i can find this
one
yep kendall i'm here underway against i
love legos 2. uh these players playing
quickly a huge problem in these
corporate chess league events has always
been the clock especially once you get
down to this 1500 1200 type rating uh
these players not always the best at
managing their time in these 10 minute
games it's 10 plus zero so no extra time
no increments if you flag when you're up
a queen too bad tough luck
should have played faster in the opening
and what we have here is a pretty
classic queen and pawn end game so
with queens on the board you might
expect that the defending side has some
chances to kind of go after the king
distract from the power of having a past
pawn but that's actually uh not really
the case uh black played a very good
move just now queen to b2 the idea
uh of defending along this diagonal and
with this diagonal defended white can't
check from the side can't check from the
fronts can't check from the diagonals
and the king is powerful enough to guard
all of these squares so there's really
no way for white to harass this king in
the meantime the queen is going to do a
very easy job of supporting this pawn
down the board should be an easy win
here for kendalum
so with that i'm expecting a win on
board one for enterprise and a win on
board three for enterprise they've
already got a draw on board two so off
to a very very strong start
let's keep it moving go on down to big
daddy jazz 64.
see what we've got here
although he doesn't seem to be
online uh oh maybe his opponent is maybe
ina dekeva
no neither of them are online maybe some
trouble getting connected here it is the
first round
let's see but i do have the final board
for the enterprise uh
against doherty matchup
nirvan b playing for enterprise and mike
schimweg
playing for dardy
so on this one
uh it looks like a rook on a it was just
captured is that is that right
what on earth just happened here
okay this is
this is this is something else this is
some this is some kind of chest i'm not
familiar with um
mike going for a very non-standard
opening here you know it's good to
control the center uh develop your
pieces in the normal way
um
rook h6 not always great
um but it looked like it was going to
work out for a moment here so we did
capture that exchange
bishop b7
is some some kind of tactic that i don't
know about and then after queen takes b7
castles and then takes on b2 so
of course um the queen and rook are in
tension here
um and so this was missed by black and
white on the next turn and then white
realized that this rook was capturable
so nirvan actually starting to take over
the game now and this looks like
checkmate this looks a lot like
checkmate we might see an early result
here on this game
i think both of these players would do
well to get some some help from their
teammates especially on the opening
principles
and on just just the basics you got to
make sure that your pieces are defended
that they aren't just hanging
very important stuff
and to my surprise actually not to my
surprise it looks like kamikaze knight
did end up winning that that first game
as expected that attack in the sicilian
was just going to be way too strong
and with that i
think
enterprise is really off to to a pretty
massive lead here
um
thus far it's only the
one game i believe but let's take a look
how did black end up doing
yep so as expected black was able to
escort this pawn all the way down the
board uh white got a single check but
black was able to defend the king and
now it's just an extra queen for for
black so pendulum gonna take this one
home as well and with that enterprises
is very much in a bad way
uh but let's stick with it let's see
what c cell can do here against the the
strong john boyer um we have an english
early e3 uh and d4 okay
so in this opening black has given up
the dark square bishop for the knights
and in return this is somewhat fractured
white's pawns and made this bishop a
little bit harder to develop
but white's not so sad about that always
because this pawn is going to give us a
lot of extra support for the d-pawn c5
is an interesting idea by c cell he
trades off his double pawns
castle's the king so far so good and now
we see knight a5 by by kamikaze knight
here so
john is really looking to prevent the c
pawn from advancing any further if he
can get some kind of setup with bishop
e6 maybe bishop c4 maybe knight c4
where he can really effectively blockade
uh this c pawn then white's going to
have a hard time finishing development
this bishop in particular
while it is unopposed could grow to be
kind of uncomfortable sitting on c1 if
this knight lands on the c4 square
uh that being said i like c cell's last
move queen a4 is challenging both the
knight and this uh
this c4 square
and i am starting to wonder if white can
get away with playing this i don't think
so so that's why we play bishop a3 if
white played c4 i think bishop a6
actually gave white some some serious
problems
uh so bishop a3 getting developed now
queen to d7
again it's all about the c4 square here
black is trying to trade off the queens
because white's queen controls the
square and black's queen did not so if
white were to accept this trade again
that's gonna further weaken white's
control over c4 okay instead white moves
the pawn to c4 which is good in theory
but bad in practice uh you're a queen
your queen is dead the queen is dead
long live the queen
um
that's unfortunate cecil i feel like was
playing this this game very very
reasonably was playing off to a good
start seem to understand some of the
strategy but the queen hangs will will
tell the tale for uh for c cell here
um
so with that let's check back in on
board two we still have money ballin
against desrats they had that quick draw
in the first round and let's see
moneyballin i believe is the player for
enterprise yep
and c cell uh sorry not c cell does rat
playing for darty
so what is this position
what is this position white has more
pieces does white not have more pieces
one piece two piece
red piece blue piece
um yeah white has more pieces i figured
it out
uh
black doesn't really have much in
exchange for the piece
but
for the moment these knights in
particular are a little bit awkwardly
placed they're sort of stepping on each
other's toes you don't really want to
have your knights connected like this uh
you can imagine like if the knights were
on e3 and e4 instead or even e3 and f3
instead they would control a much
broader swath of the board when they're
connected like this they can be a little
bit vulnerable and you see actually
moneyballin trying to set up some kind
of tactic here where after e4 this
knight would have to move away and the
knight on d2 would be would be
undefended now i'm not sure the tactic
even immediately works white has stuff
like rookie one taking advantage of this
pin but moneyballon's head is in the
right place um like i would go for f5
here like f5 threaten e4 try and get
some tactics going try and get your
pawns rolling
and
get some some counter play here
moneyball and also way down on the clock
not where you want to be
um in this corporate chess league 10
plus 0 games they go by fast they really
go by fast
meanwhile the results continue to filter
in here i believe
enterprise has all but clinched the
match against darty um john boyer
kamikaze knight on board one did end up
winning both his games going 2-0
big daddy jazz seems to have won by
forfeit against ina dekeva so now we
understand why those games weren't
getting underway big daddy jazz was
there ready to connect inna dakeva
perhaps a no-show unfortunately
um oh oh and very bad news for bayer it
looks as though uh two of bayer's
players are our no shows as well i'm
looking at vindy getting crossed out on
the pairing sheet and n klein bear also
getting crossed out i think those are
forfeit losses meaning they were not
able to attend the first round hopefully
some of these players can get connected
otherwise it might not be the most
competitive night at the corporate chess
league
very very tough to to come back if
you're giving away free points
um kendra lim also winning his second
game against i love legos too
um and sorry the board might have
stopped updating there for a bit let's
see what happens
um yeah we saw rookie eights rookie one
h6 was a slightly odd choice bishop d4
also a very strange decision uh when
you're up a piece like this you don't
really need to go for these kinds of
complications
just simple chess is often the best way
to go especially if you are
um if you're already winning you know
complications favor the player with the
worst position because once things get
complicated anything gonna happen you
might lose a piece your opponent might
lose a piece but you don't really need
to win any more pieces you're already
winning so follow yes to sarawan's
advice
one of his favorite acronyms is kiss
which stands for keep it simple stupid
just keep it simple
and then you can't go wrong
so instead we are not keeping it simple
we're playing knight takes e5 which i do
think loses a piece to a number of
different lines white can play rook
takes uh d4 now white can take on e5 and
then take on d2
um yeah black is black is just getting a
piece back um that's
plain and simple
white of course is still i think
to be preferred thanks to the strong c5
pawn but actually i'm not even sure our
strong c5 pawn is is going to be
surviving too much longer yeah we have
our pick of knights to capture i like
taking this one on g4 because it keeps
the pressure against b4 alive
and it also threatens takes on g2 so
just a fork
now rook takes b4 and materials equal
and desrats not keeping it simple
allowing moneyballin back into the game
giving him some life and now it's just
an equal end game
um
i still think white is going to be a bit
better because the white king has a much
faster path into the center especially
if black were to trade off these rooks
this king is going to appear on d4 like
lightning
but black
is sort of pointing out that the black
king is is going to make it there as
well
but again yeah f4 now and white has a
really good control over all of these
central squares this is sort of keeping
the black king at bay
although as i'm as i'm talking about the
the beauty of white's position pawns are
starting to fall so
white's going all in now on the c pawn
giving up both the g and the h pawns but
i'm not sure i'm a believer
this black bishop already is controlling
uh controlling
yeah controlling too much controlling c8
and the c pawn falls money ballin going
from losing to i think just clearly
winning in a matter of
five or ten moves and honestly like
one minute took a single minute for this
position to turn around
um if i was white there i was gonna try
something tricky like
um king e4 f5 but i don't think it
worked even if you get that in there's
bishop b7 uh bishop g2 to b7 in the end
not all hope is lost though if black or
if white can trade off some pawns and
then sacrifice the knight for the
remaining pawns
then it would be a draw however with
good play i don't think that ever
happens
and but not to make fun of these players
but i think that uh even i might
struggle with a minute on the clock to
win this position against a really
strong player so i still think anything
could happen here
if i wouldn't feel confident winning
against magnus carlsen then i'm not
confident that these players are going
to play it well uh play it well either
we get knight back to e2
and again money balance time starting to
tick down he's at least secured a draw
on chess.com's rules if you flag and
your opponent has just a knight it is
always a draw no matter what
on lead chess sometimes you win
depending on the other material
remaining but on chess.com that's just a
draw
and now king g6 and i think white might
be securing this draw it looks like the
pawns are going to end up falling
looks like there's no way to defend the
pawns so
wild back and forth here uh moneyballin
not able to convert with so little time
on the clock allows white to to save at
least a half point for for his team
by the way if you're wondering what's at
stake in these matches
um
very weird weird moves but always all is
still okay for white i would have i
would have snatched um this pawn
on h6
at least three times by now but that's
okay
that's all right it's not going anywhere
unless you play knight f5 knight of five
of course horrible move because the
bishop could pin
and finally
okay finally the pawn has been captured
i can breathe a little bit easier now
we'll just bring our king back here
bring the knight back to g3 this this
game this game is over big draw
i'm confident that desrat can configure
this one figure this one out
yep just bring the knight to g3
now you can pass in too many squares
it's impossible for black to control all
let's see six squares that the knight
can move to so then i will always have a
square and then it can always come back
to g3 no way for black to take over the
dark square
so it's just just going to be a clear
draw
but what was i saying what are these
players playing for us of course they
are competing for grand prix points uh
the four teams with the most grand prix
points at the end of the season will
advance to the playoffs so how do you
score grand prix points well if you win
the head-to-head team match then you get
10 points awarded to your grand prix
score and by 10 i mean 20. you get 20
points awarded to your grand prix score
now in addition to that you also get
your individual match scores so for
example john boyer went 2-0 against
csell so that's another two grand prix
points for enterprise and unfortunately
zero for doherty from that head-to-head
matchup now moneyballin and desrat have
just officially split one to one so that
is one point towards the grand prix
score for each team um pendulum beat i
love legos two two to zero so that's two
more points for enterprise and so on and
so forth so every single game matters
for these points but of course the the
20-point bonus for winning the match
going to be the most important here
tonight
um so with that this game is a draw we
have just one game remaining in
uh
this matchup between enterprise and
darty that's going to be between
nirvan b and mike schimwag again two of
the craziest players we've seen in the
corporate chess league so far
so what's going on here so nirvanbi does
seem to understand some more principles
than uh than his opponent mike but we
saw mike
have some opportunities in the last game
there were some pieces hung there was
some some dangers for nirvan so despite
the lack of opening knowledge um
mike is is a force to be reckoned with
at least in this matchup
i'm half expecting black to take on f2
next and neither player to realize that
this knight defends on f2
but maybe i am selling these players
short
okay mike does notice the threat to f2
so he defends with the rook again it was
already defended once with the knight on
h3
but
defends with the rook as well
robster says no mask of course tonight i
am coming to you from the comfort of my
home rather than in front of a live
audience so no need for the mask tonight
no need for the mask tonight's home
because i got snowed in mentioned it at
the top of the show
but the roads are looking pretty rough
out there so couldn't make it into the
chess club for today
okay bishop takes f2 plate anyways this
is attacked three times now defended
only once so mike
can and should go ahead and capture this
bishop he does so with the rook i would
have preferred the knights you of course
want to lose the the piece that is less
valuable knight being worth three rook
being worth five so now black captures
five points of material whereas if you
were capturing a knight would only
capture three points of material would
have been a little bit better
um
and i think this is the final game in
the round we do actually have one more
that we can take a look at
in the ascension bayer match up that's
going to be between davinators2
and nm
somebody else
uh let's find out here
although they do not seem to be playing
their second game i think this is the
only game that's uh that's in progress
at this moment between um between nirvan
b and mike schimwag so once this one
wraps up
then we will be on to round two
so yeah this is the last one it looks
like david anders uh final game against
uh nmc gin just wrapped up they split
one to one
so this is it
this is our final game of the match
and to
give
some more details let's see where our
standings are at right now i think this
is accurate so enterprise going eight
points up against uh darty dardy i did
they only get one points
is that true they did only score one
point so far but mike fighting for that
second point here in this round
um meanwhile ascension scoring six
points against bayer of four of those
points i think were forfeit wins
bayer
getting two points with their their two
players that did manage to play
um and i'm not sure why we're giving
color art two points and edward jones
one point so i think
that perhaps these players could not
field full teams uh for the first round
here so they are playing extra matches
so i do see alex kurford there um
playing for edward jones as an
individual scoring one point and then i
believe gary mindel must be playing for
color art in the extra matches as well
uh getting two points for for color arts
so that's how those points appeared
um so of course as i mentioned uh those
are the board points but they are about
to get 20 extra points if you are
ascension or enterprise and now those 20
points are for winning the first match
and i'm being told alex's game is still
going let's peek in on that as well
looks like they're in a bit of time
pressure so alex fighting for that
second point
for edward jones
uh with the white pieces here he is up a
full piece in a number of pawns but down
to 34 seconds so this this game
could still
uh have some intrigue
okay bishop f6 this looks like a
desirable move because it puts the
bishop on a square where it's defended
but actually now g6 is going to be hard
to attain because g6 will always leave
this bishop behind so long as black's
king is here to provide some pressure
um i don't really like king e6 it puts
your king
opposite this rook uh giving yourself
some opportunities to hang some tactics
but what's important above all else here
is is just moving quickly of course
black needs to
keep the pressure on the clock given
enough time alex is going to win this
position
a hundred times out of a hundred so you
have to really pressure the clock make
sure you give him just enough problems
that he has to use his remaining 19
seconds solving those problems and not
checkmating your king
yeah king g4 not in love with this i
think we needed to leave the king on f5
to stop this g6 idea and then go hunting
with the rook all right we're not going
to talk about that uh it's time pressure
things get missed um rook a3 b4 rook b3
now i like this we are snagging this
pawn or forcing some awkward move okay
but yeah rook b4 is too much after
bishop to e7 uh white's gonna see that
one
white's gonna see that one
okay alex will make a queen now
and has seven seconds left to checkmates
can he do it
here comes the third queen here comes
the rook
or the queen
alex wins by checkmate getting that
second point for edward jones all right
peeking back in here let's see what's
going on this f2 sacrifice seems to have
paid off because mike did not recapture
on f2 he had two different ways to do it
but did not find either one
that allowed nirvan to sort of take over
he captures on g3 now swings over queen
b3 and this is where the position
currently stands queen c2 that's gonna
be good enough i think um black going
for the classic idea of collecting all
the pieces rather than trying
uh
trying to just
checkmate by force although this is a
checkmating threat if mike does not see
that this might is capturable on h3 here
so checkmate is being threatened
look out
[Music]
look out mike
queen e3 okay that does allow the
checkmate
will nirvan play it he will and with
that our first round comes to a close
so that's going to give one more point
over to
uh
enterprise i believe
that's going to bring their total up to
9
which plus 20 is going to be 29 points
in the first round uh that's that's
going to be a pretty sizable lead for
for enterprise gonna be tough to catch
up there
meanwhile ascension with a very good
first round as well will end with 26
after round one
heading into into round two
so what does round two look like we've
got bayer up against enterprise and
ascension up against dardy so the clash
of the titans ascension and enterprise
at the top of the leaderboard will not
happen tonight so we'll see which of
these teams is able to extend their lead
and which of these teams ends up uh
getting caught perhaps
could get caught in my home i am at home
i've mentioned it i think once or twice
but uh we got snowed in here in st louis
for today so i'm happy that i can still
bring you guys this coverage from the
comfort of my living room um but
could not make it into the studio today
could not make it into the studio
so we'll give the players just a few
moments here to get ready for this
second round to get underway uh to give
you the head-to-head
uh bayer versus enterprise that's going
to look like vindy on board one against
kamikaze knight now vindi did not show
up for the first round here so hopefully
he is just running late and can attend
for round two otherwise going to be a a
tall hill to climb for
for bayer
board two is going to be crossed to pj
against money ballin board three is
incline bear against pendulum and on
board four we've got nmc jim
uh jyn against big daddy jazz 64.
um
we also have ascension uh squaring off
against uh dougherty which i believe is
the match that i want to follow i think
that one will be a little bit more
competitive
is going to be maurice gp against c cell
on board one uh we're going to see s
gilmore 999 up against des rats deseret
i believe the only scoring player for
doherty thus far they had a tough first
round
um so desrat gonna try and uh keep it up
keep it up for his team we've got oak
ave against i love legos two on board
three david naders against ina decayva
inakeva also was a no show for round one
uh and
eberlemd
ibralend
eberlemmed
ibrelmd
something like that is up against mike
shimweg on
board five and i hear the sound of chess
moves being played which makes me think
we are off and rolling um alex curford
now is playing gary mindel 66 so this is
essentially the edward jones versus
color art match
i think both of these teams were only
able to field one player tonight so it
won't count for that 20 point
match score bonus for winning a match
but it will count for uh for board
points so
bragging rights at stake here edward
jones versus uh color art sort of a
preview for matches to come
and we also have this game underway uh
for moneyballin versus crosta pj
so this one is part of the bayer
enterprise matchup let's just take a
look here see how we're doing
um e4 knight f6 we have an alakan
with knight c3 and then d5 i'm not at
all familiar with what's going on here
and that's a free pawn for moneyballing
that's just an extra pawn
a little conservative here brings the
knight back to d6 but an extra pawn is
an extra pawn all right let's actually
stick with uh alex here see how he's
doing as well
uh we have d4 e5 oh my goodness the the
england strikes again uh white's too
afraid to take the pawn on e5 just
defends
and now we have some kind of exchange
french
what a world we're living in um actually
a very good position for white thus far
very good position i don't love what
alex did with this bishop here
it does induce these pawns to move
forward but i'm not sure that white is
so unhappy about that
black now though looking to do some very
nasty things to white's position he's
going to drop this bishop back in
threaten checkmate here and try and
uh push push a little bit harder try and
give bite some problems
while webster with some strong words for
for alex in fairness i'm not sure this
is the position you expect to get after
you play the england so alex might just
be a little bit out of his depth here uh
not totally sure what to do but he again
i i do think this is a very nice
repositioning for him he's bringing this
bishop back into the game
and getting the pieces out one way or
the other
uh might look to play something like a5
as well trying to actually make use of
this b4 pawn
yeah g3 is a little bit um unfortunate
for whites it does allow you this
opportunity to play something like
bishop f4 it's going to contest this
bishop on c7
this is quote-unquote black's good
bishop so he might not be unhappy about
getting that piece off the board
uh however of course this does come with
some weaknesses around the king white's
just gonna have to be very cognizant of
those gonna have to find a clever way to
actually escape from this this annoying
annoying pin on
the
whatever diagonal this is the d1 h5
diagonal i guess you could say
um so if i'm white i'm probably looking
to play bishop f4 take this bishop off
the board and then i want to play king
g2 h3 and maybe even g4
and my idea is without the dark square
bishop i'm not as worried about
weakening this diagonal so much and if i
can force this bishop to to unpin my
knight i want to play like knight e5
enjoy some extra space in the position
and maybe i get to survive with my
weaknesses since i've traded off a
couple a couple minor pieces
um but problems to solve for white not
so many problems to solve for black if
i'm entirely honest all black has to do
here is finish development and contest
the the e file now that can be easier
said than done knight bd7 would lose a
piece to bishop f4 so you know somewhat
there are some problems i suppose it's a
little bit awkward to get this final
piece into the game maybe that's why we
see a5 maybe he's looking at something
like knight a6 even
bishop takes f6 i hate this move i think
this move might just lose by force it
brings a whites or black's queen into
the attack on this knight on f3 king f
king g2 is forced now
um and again it leaves this bishop now
completely unopposed giving up your
bishops for knights unprovoked is
more often than not gonna be very very
bad even in the nimzo indian black
usually waits for white to play
something like a3 putting the question
to the bishop before snapping that
knight off on on c3 bishops are good you
know knights knights are pieces but like
bishops are good pieces uh you don't
want to be giving them away like that
for for free definitely not for free
um so gary mendel uh giving himself a
tough task now and
are the other games going am i just not
following the the people i need to be
following this could be
um
actually this very much could be let's
see what we can do
try and follow maurice gp
ah and these games are going it's just
that the
bayer enterprise match has not they only
have one game going
very strange okay so s gilmore
999 is also playing
against des rats we've got oak ave on
board three
we've got
david nader's
who is
not playing
um and
ibrahim or something evil md
on the last board okay these games are
all underway
and where we will leave this game is
with queen takes f3
um
gonna be a tough
is it gonna be tough
it's gonna be at least a little bit
tough for white to escape from this one
if you take on c7 i can take on d3 i
guess bishop e2 might be saving uh
saving the day here
for white you have to move the queen and
then i can take then i can take okay
none of that gets found now i am just
going to take here and be up a piece
alex can find that let us take a look at
this
um
ascension versus darty match up so
we're looking i believe from a sentence
perspective here we've got maurice gp
versus c cell on board one maurice gp
playing for ascension
um and a fairly level position black has
an extra pawn but white does have this
super strong bishop against the knight
so some chances for both sides i would
say right as soon as you try to start
pushing these pawns then this bishop is
going to come even more to life on this
super long diagonal great diagonal for
the bishop so it's tough to make use of
this extra pawn at least yet
black of course should be doing better
with the extra pawn
but it could very very quickly actually
turn around if some of these pawns start
to drop off the board
yeah for example queen to b3
asking you how do you intend to defend
this pawn on b7
and i don't have the answers i guess
rook a7 is is one way to go about it
but circus seven maybe not the most
comfortable
yeah i think it's gotta be rook a7 here
you don't really want to play something
like rook eb8 you would maybe rather
double this rook onto the a8 square um
when in doubt you don't want to go
passive in these kinds of positions
being an active uh going for active
counter play instead of passive defense
is almost always going to be better
and again sea salt doing a good job here
of just immobilizing these pawns you
can't really touch either of these pawns
or else
both the bishop and the major pieces
are immediately capturing
immediately capturing your guys
so maurice with problems to solve here
he does play rook a to b8 i think that's
the worst of the options to defend this
pawn if you are going to be passive be
passive with the other rook you want to
leave this guy on the active a file
where he can pressure this a pawn
now no active play at all for black and
i think with white here i'm really
seriously considering a4 a5 a6 and cecil
does start to go for it
um why do i want to play a4a5 a6 well i
want to break down the defender of this
c6 pawn get my rooks into the game and
once c6 falls then again this bishop's
just going to be um going to be
monstrous monstrous on the long diagonal
we'll see if c cell has the guts to go
through it though uh it's one thing to
play a4a5 it's another thing to play a6
as a pawn sacrifice
yeah now knight to c7 is good it does
prevent a6 because i would capture with
the knight leaving everything sort of
together in my position at least for the
moment
this also offers the queen trade i'm
expecting queen b6 makes a lot of sense
to me
makes a lot of sense to me
now if knight d5
maybe white goes back maybe queen c5 is
an improvement for for
white i think queen c5 makes sense i
don't think we want to capture this
knight ever on d5 like i said the
bishop's monster don't want to give up
our best minor piece
our only minor piece in this case but
it's still a very very good one
so queen c5 instead renews the threat of
a6
uh and if rook a8 now i think we bring
one of the rooks to the b file and we
can continue with with active counter
play
yeah rook b1 i love what c cell's doing
here keeping the balance keeping the
threats up
and the questions on maurice he brings
the rook back to b8 again i don't love
going passive in these positions
the donations go to me or to st louis i
believe we are currently fundraising for
uh our scholastics programs so if you
think that's uh the mission of spreading
chess is an important one that is where
the money goes putting chests in schools
teaching more kids how to play the game
so very worthy cause even if it doesn't
go into my pocket maybe that's a more
worthy cause uh at least in some
people's opinion but uh give it to the
kids give it to the kids
uh queen takes e7 and this is now going
to be tactically good for white a6 is
coming this rook is now pinned on the b
file and i see absolutely no way to
defend this b-pawn you can move it
but then white's gonna switch gears
gonna come over to the c file and the
bishop again is
very well placed controlling the
queening square for this pawn once these
things get
disrupted
um
but it is gonna come down to specifics
here if okay well this is
this is a blunder rooks move sideways
yeah so
strong defense from white so far but
then i'm not sure why we faltered at the
last moment here we could have gone for
bishop takes d5 uh without losing our a
pawn
so i definitely would have preferred
that now it's a five versus four so
you've probably heard of four versus
three end games you've maybe heard of
three versus two end games but five
versus four is tough
so the general wisdom here
is that as you keep adding on those
extra pairs of pawns it gets harder and
harder to draw so four versus three
should be a more or less trivial draw
three versus two very trivial draw
um but five versus four
if black knows what they're doing here
they could make it somewhat difficult
for
for white to hold
that being said
this is not an endgame i've studied in
depth so i have nothing bad to say if
these players misplay this because i
don't even know what miss playing this
looks like to be honest
um we get rick to a6 i like what white's
doing with this rook in general in these
end games you want the rook far away on
the side where it can deliver annoying
lateral checks and can attack these
pawns also from the side
black does seem to be handling things
pretty well
i'm just slowly but surely expanding now
black should probably do the same thing
that i just advised white to do which is
bring this rook off to the side where it
can attack and harass the white king
white did not leave himself with much
shelter
instead we get e4 and now
e takes f3
and this these were some slightly
strange decisions by by both sides
slightly slightly strange
okay it looks like white is corralling
the f3 pawn but again black is able to
get active okay
way too close the rooks are long range
pieces you want to make use of that
power to to check far from the side now
rook c3 check is never possible but rick
a3 check would have been you know long
range pieces get them far away from the
kings where they cannot be harassed
um and very very interesting end game
now now my my heart's telling me this
one should actually be winning with good
play the e3 pawn is going to be way too
weak and again
if we can just get this rook out to the
side i think that's what's going to give
white the most problems e4 is is also
going to be possible now
i don't love h6g5 again with every pawn
that gets traded it's going to be closer
to a draw we absolutely need this rook
over here okay maurice finds it brings
the rook out to the side finally
now check king e4 and white has serious
problems so i think white needs to do
the exact same thing come to b2
again c2 is going to be way too close we
needed to be on b2 so after king e4 we
can deliver the check from the side push
the black king back now white is going
to be lost and c cell finds it but finds
it a move too late
so if you know if you learn one thing
from these end games uh check from the
side from a distance the rooks are long
range pieces don't go so close
they're not effective up close against
the king
now this is going to be a two versus
zero should be a pretty clean win for
maurice if he's able to
solve a few final problems here i like
the rook on the second i would go over
to a2 or h2 again far away as possible
from the king rook a2 i love it we can
block this check with d4
and now there's no way to prevent the
king from going king e3
um or just yeah f2 f1 as well
so you see how many turns white had to
spend to attack this rook a single time
that's why long range pieces are are
good farther away from the king
and with f1 queen coming next we do see
c cell resigning uh pretty instructive
rook end game there even if it wasn't
played to perfection
um okay so we've got a quick uh 1 1-0
for maurice oak ave did win his first
game against i love legos 2 and it looks
like
des rat against s gilmore they are also
in their second game also win for s
gilmore
so that is three quick points for
ascension
uh in that first round let's see how
eber or
ibrahim i'm gonna i'm gonna need some
help on pronouncing that one
let's see how they're doing against each
other mike versus eberlin
we have
uh a position
that i think is best described as
totally random this looks like someone
got a handful of chess pieces tossed
them up in the air and they they sort of
fell on the chessboard like this
um so i have no idea what's going on i
just need to count pieces okay black has
an extra bishop
white has two extra pawns for it
and also this king is on h4
these pawns look somewhat threatening
and none of black's pieces are really
working together at all they're all sort
of just scattered randomly like i said
so
white's piece is a little bit more
harmonious but black does have more of
them so i think black should be doing
well here even though these pawns look
somewhat scary
a little bit's uh
a little bit tough here
yeah doris is doing great the club
has closed it did close yesterday so her
classes yesterday did not get streamed
also we are running low on stream
operators i believe so she's been
teaching classes at the club but they
just haven't always made it to the
internet but she should be back next
week
if all goes well
okay rook g8 is going to blunder a rook
uh ibrahim can just capture that with
the knights
will they find it
knight takes rook knight takes rook
i believe i believe in eber
i believe
take the rook believe in you take the
rook
no the rook will not be captured today
rook f4 instead
okay
i
can't watch this game okay
what's going on here oak ave had a quick
win in the first round against i love
legos 2. i love legos 2 trying to get
some revenge now doing so with a very
scary looking pawn on c6 queen a6 to b7
is a big boy threat that's that's
serious don't don't take that one
lightly
um
that being said i'm not sure i love this
last move bishop d7 that would allow
rook takes d7
perhaps when after
takes back king b7
it actually still looks very very
awkward for black to deal with to be
honest so maybe bishop d7 is okay i
would have preferred just queen a6 just
leave this bishop hanging on g4
and then just go you know knight d5
coming into c7
also bring this rook over slowly but
surely it's going to give black some
problems
yeah so rook d8 knight d5 but now this
can be captured
this can be captured here can and should
be be captured
and i think black might have survived
the uh the brunt of the attack now white
is actually up a piece in this position
so
it's not all roses yet okay queen f7 is
going to allow white to to capture this
with check i'm not sure why this was
allowed uh we also might have mate we
can check check the king goes back to a8
and we take this rook
and yeah then then we win and queen c8
is mate so queen c6 is forced checkmate
for i love legos too will he find it or
will he succumb to the temptation of
taking this pawn with check in one turn
will he succumb to the temptation all
right we've got someone on team beggar
it's not been a great night for bayer so
far
but let's see how they're doing today
against enterprise
yeah i think they bear had two no-shows
unfortunately so
tough to win your match when half your
team is missing but crass to pj and nmc
gin both putting in the work fighting it
out for bayer getting points where they
can
yeah knight c7 was played
i love legos 2 not able to find that
forced checkmating sequence i think we
still have force checkmate probably
after queen a6 queen a7 rook c1 but i'm
not gonna expect anybody to find that
rook c1 is a classy move leaves this
knight on c7 leaves this queen a6 threat
alive
um
and casts a little bit of a mating net
some mating net ideas here for i love
legos 2. that's that's a classy move
queen c6 also threatened and is probably
mate in two
maybe not quite two but but mate in a
few
so queen c6 check it's found it is found
now no matter where the king goes knight
a6 check is devastating
absolutely devastating actually queen a8
is mate in one no matter where the king
goes we don't even need knight a6 we
have queen a8
so what uh what a find by i love legos
too he missed the forced sequence but
then recovered with this nice rook c1
move again putting
uh black in a meeting net and
immediately queen a8 i love legos two
getting it done scoring the first point
for darty in this match against
ascension it looks like mike did end up
beating iberlim so with a surprise
checkmate on the side of the board i'm
not sure anybody saw that coming rook h3
checkmate and this king has absolutely
nowhere to go so mike picks up his first
point of the corporate chess league and
the first point for doherty that brings
their score down to two against
ascension
and what else do we have let's see
let's check back in on this top board
here we've got game number two for
maurice gp against c cell and a rook has
just been captured a queen has just been
promoted and it looks as if uh c cell
again
is gonna be in a bad way here maurice
with the extra rook
should be able to win this game
um that being said he's running a little
bit low on pawns and black does have a
pawn on b2
it's theoretically possible to mess this
up but now after bishop b2 pinning
attacking the pinned bishop
this is yeah this is over now no pieces
left on the board for black
all you can hope for is stalemate that's
going to get it done for maurice
we also have a second win for s gilmore
over desrats looks like resignation here
after knight e5
it's a strange moment to resign i'm not
sure oh okay checkmate in one was
threatened and then 95 was played and
then deseret realized that they didn't
defend the mate and one not such a
strange moment to resign after all me
personally i would never resign here i
would uh you know hope against hope that
my i just confused my opponent too much
and they didn't uh didn't see that they
had threatened mate
um but
des rats uh perhaps does the
embarrassment resigning
which you know you can't really blame
anybody for we've all been there just
resigning out of embarrassment
um and with that we only have one game
left in the ascension versus doherty
matchup it's gonna be down to ibrahim
against mike can eberlin get his revenge
defeat mike shimweg
uh or will mike
uh get his first sweep of the match
um if you are keeping track of the total
scores uh enterprise is going to win
their match against bayer giving them 20
more grand prix points and ascension has
clinched the match against already so
they will also get that 20 point bonus
for winning the team match
i believe there are a couple games still
left we have
money ballin against crass to pj
happening up here oh in a wild position
we'll stick with this one
and i do think big daddy jazz did end up
uh playing in this round as well
yeah we've got him against nmc gin uh
and then
i believe that's all we have remaining
just three games left for tonight in the
corporate chess league
resigning limits the public humiliation
fair enough fair enough again we've all
been there even the private humiliation
is sometimes enough to resign
i believe in other games they call it
the shame concede i think this is like
some hearthstone hearthstone term that
i've heard petersfielder throw around
um and you know fair enough sometimes
you take the minus ev just to uh save
your mental health
um in this case moneyballin putting on a
clinic here putting on a clinic
sure yes he is up a piece but look at
how these knights dominate literally
every piece on the board for black this
knight is keeping this bishop stuck on
a8
and
controlling this pawn on e6 this knight
stopping the rooks from coming to the b
file or the f file and the pawn of the
knight together totally hampering
black's major pieces along down the
center of the board these three pieces
alone are keeping back
like
25 points of material for for black
that's absolutely wild
black does get a queen trade off but now
it's it's at too great of a cost uh
white is going to cash in here get this
knight uh give up this knight for that
rook
and yeah rookie five any number of
things what uh what a position moneyball
and got there that is
that is domination if i've ever seen it
uh moneyballing just activating his
extra rook now and once this rook comes
into the game
that that will be gg
so why don't we check in over here with
big daddy jazz against nm
nmc jin
not sure how meant to pronounce those
three consonants all in a row i'm gonna
go with nmc maybe it's
in i i don't know
um
and white is going to be up in exchange
here looks like nmc gin did beat big
daddy jazz in the first round with a 400
point upset but uh mr jazz does seem to
be on the better side of things this
time extra exchange this knight is
actually kind of trapped on b3 tough to
evacuate this knight here uh maybe you
go rook a2 hoping for knight d2 the
second the knight lands on d2 rookie two
comes on the board and and you're pinned
so
looks like pretty smooth sailing here
for mr jazz
um
and with that i think this game is about
to end um across the pj down to 18
seconds so we'll stick with this to see
the
brutal finish
um it looks like moneyballin trying to
find a checkmate here understandably
b3 check doesn't quite do it there's
king b4
uh rook a4 check allows king b5 maybe
yeah this looks like the fastest we go
rook a4 king b5 rook d3 to b3 and that's
the end of the game
um i guess king d5 was
a reason to not go for that but king d5
i mean
obviously it's all a little academic
doesn't really matter
doesn't really matter in the end
yeah anything here the check is good
enough extra queen is coming this bishop
is still so so sad
so so sad
and the win on time and that leaves us
with just two games remaining
okay let's see what happened here looks
like white did pick up this pawn on b5
but in return black did manage to get
this knight back back into the game
if i am big daddy jazz's coach here i'm
telling him just take the busy time take
the time out of your busy schedule play
a move like h3 because i'm not
interested in seeing you give up free
points uh
due to
you know brain slips where you just
happen to blunder back rank checkmate
it's okay just just take the time
defend your king
nobody's perfect everybody hangs
backrank mate sometimes so just don't
let it be you don't let it be you when
you are this winning
that being said black doing a good job
here of not giving white enough time to
do that so
rick b6 rook d8 i'm not sure which the
better one was to defend this d-pawn but
we do see rook b6
yeah there was a big upset in the first
round there smirky big upset uh
nmc gin did defeat
mr jazz as i've started calling him okay
finally g3 we are not going to see
backrank mate get hung by white in this
game now the question is is he going to
be able to convert this exchange up
position
it shouldn't be the hardest conversion
in the world but it can be kind of tough
again rooks long range pieces in all
these end games you want to be using
them from the side to challenge your
opponent's king challenge your
opponent's remaining pawns
and in this case black did a good job of
getting behind the past pawn so we can't
really do that effectively so that's
when you want to get active get to the
side of these pawns and start making
your own threats so rook a7 i love rook
a1 i want to see rook a7 next
and even d7 starts to become a threat
rook b to b7 might be a threat start
trying to take these guys
lots of options here for for white
you can also uh try to activate the king
but it can be a little bit tough with
both the knight and the rook left on the
board your king is going to get a little
bit harassed checked around a bit
especially because black's pieces are on
very stable squares
yeah here i'd be tempted just to play
rook a7 i don't really mind giving up my
d-pawn if it means i get to trade off my
opponent's rook um in general when
you're in exchange up just the pure rook
versus minor piece is a lot easier to
handle than two rooks versus a rook and
a minor piece uh your two rooks kind of
step on each other's toes sometimes they
perform the same tasks whereas the minor
piece is able to sort of work around the
rook whether that's a bishop or a knight
the minor piece is able to sort of cover
the squares that the rook cannot
whereas of course when you have two of
the same piece they do all the same
things
okay white gave rookie one check instead
white really concerned with losing this
pawn
so he's going to give this check make
sure that pawn stays alive
a quick knight f8 now is going to allow
this rook into e7 if white once it would
allow takes d6 but again
i don't really mind giving up this pawn
if it means i can simplify
rook b7 again would be very strong yes
so white finally understands that you do
not need to keep this d pawn to win the
game you just need to get active and
just start capturing everything your
opponent has so rook b7 great move uh
and i don't see the way out now for
black if you try rook f5 i just take it
i go d7 you're gonna have to give up
your knight for my pawn
uh and i will win the game pretty easily
if you don't if you don't play rook f5
then i'm taking with one of these pieces
like 96 i probably take this way if
anything else i probably take this way
target your knight and you're going to
have a very difficult time
explaining how you're going to save any
of your pieces
very very difficult
uh mr jazz also got a little bit low on
the clock for my liking but two minutes
left is going to be plenty of time to
put this one away i think yeah so rick
takes d6 does allow white to just win
this knight by force
so it's now a full extra rook for big
daddy jazz
and now we can go rick f6
trade off black's last piece
and with a rook to the good i trust that
this will end in white's favor although
outside stalemate chances this is
actually going to be mate if you play h6
check over checkmate this is going to
work the exact same way as long as white
can find it
check and mate
check
and me
checkmate
check
check that's not check dangerous
one legal move left for black we can
take it
and we can give another check
what you don't want to do is
okay i guess there's no real way to
blunder stalemate here but rook f5 is
good enough
okay and we'll get there one way or the
other miss the mate in two but you'll
still get there i believe
okay that leaves us with just this game
remaining assuming big daddy jazz can
finish that one off we have mike
with the white pieces here in some
trouble down a full piece
with
a very symmetrical looking pawn
structure
um of unmoved pawns
but
he's also active his rook is active he's
capturing pawns he's still fighting
and the onus is going to be on black
here to figure out how to convert
of course i want to take this pawn
threaten checkmate but will mike give us
time no he won't challenges this knight
and it's missed
it's missed by eber okay
down to just the rook end game then and
this one of course should be a draw with
good play
but there is some some danger i think
for black still for example let's say
king g5 rook over maybe to a4 trying to
defend this pawn
ooh and this is actually quite nasty
quite nasty if king g2 you lose to h3
king g3 king g5
no way no you don't you lose to king g5
first king g5 first oh my god that was
actually crazy
that was actually insane if you play
king g5 here you have to save your rook
and then i go h3 check king g3 rook g1
is mate unstoppable king g5 wins a rook
in this position absolutely crazy
h3 first is not going to be the same
because now after king g5 you do have to
worry about rook takes g4
but wow crazy forced wind out of nowhere
this is some puzzle rush stuff
king g5 here just wins the game
absolutely bonkers
wild
um now we do get f5 and white is still
going to have to be very very careful
about not getting this king stuck
but i do think it's saveable now for
white with good play maybe we just play
f3 right away
okay that was not an ideal move um
neither was that
okay
this rook could be captured
and now after check this rook can be
defended so not great stuff there those
past couple moves
but happens to the best of us
um now after rook to g2 i think it's
actually white who's trying to win with
rook g5 and rick takes g4
this a pawn is still still alive um
should be i mean black should never be
losing
but black's no longer trying to win i
think
no longer trying to win
let's see what's uh
eber can come up with here he does play
rook g2 but again rift g5 and rick takes
g4 is going to be good enough for whites
and
you know i won't use the word unlosable
but
it'll look good it'll look good for
white it'll definitely look good
by the way big daddy jazz did end up
converting that game against nmc gin as
expected and this is in fact the final
game of the round
after this
we will call it quits for tonight on the
corporate chess league some really fun
games though i had a lot of fun
going over um going over these ones
all right
let's see what we got
e5 is white's choice ah okay so white
was worried about losing this f pawn
found this um unique idea to defend keep
the rook under control but of course
much much better was to take the g pawn
now g3 is psycho um
should just take this pawn on h2 and
then i think black is winning after g3
it can be captured h takes g also psycho
now this is a queen um
and that's not going to be not going to
be stoppable that queen is is going to
get there
it's it's going to get there
not much else to say
you have one trick you can go rick f6
check hope against hope that your
opponent chooses the h5 square then you
go rook f8 rookie trade but this is not
found
and now that's an extra queen it's an
extra queen for eber so mike against all
the odds was able to save his position
but then at the end of the day um
black was still able to to find his way
through
okay rook g8 now
outside chances here very outside
chances here rook g8
threaten the skewer
we can threaten the skewer
rook h4 is not gonna be enough black
would take
okay uh mike's greedy mike's a greedy
greedy guy he wants backrank checkmate
or side rank checkmate we saw him
swindle his first game with a similar
checkmate now going for the same thing
here but it's not going to pay off rick
f2 is check now black can trade off
white's last remaining piece
and we will get to see
the queen versus king technique or maybe
not maybe black will just keep that
piece on
okay rook h4 and we get to see the rook
versus king technique
now mike doesn't go for this either
um weird squares that black is choosing
for the king but so far it has not
um
not
hurt black at all and pawns do not move
backwards so that rook is free
okay we get queen b1 instead
queen b1 instead
this type of blindness is not exclusive
to lower rated players by the way
on empty boards like this where your
brain can't immediately register which
way the pawns are moving i think it's
very easy to think that that rook is
defended so not going to make too much
fun here
i've made this mistake myself to be
honest with you when the board's
entirely empty like this your brain just
has no reference point for like which
way the puns are moving can actually be
quite difficult
like my brain right now is telling me
that white is trying to go here and
queen but that's it's obviously not
not how the pieces move so
it's just too tough
okay
it looks like we might not have to see
any kind of technique here because mike
is down to 12 seconds
and and counting so
might just be a loss on the clock
although there is mate in a few here
queen to e2 i think is the fastest to
follow this up with queen g2 coming
that's assuming king g1 gets played if
king f1 gets played and this is made in
one
but none of that instead black wins by
time out
okay and with that that is the final
game of this uh first
round of the corporate chess league so
first night of the corporate chess
league of course we had two rounds
so let's take a look at the standings
here and see where that leaves us i'm
actually just gonna on the fly here
blow these up a little bit let's see
what we're working with we've got
enterprise scoring 18 board points now
if my understanding is correct that's
going to be plus 40 points for winning
both of their matches
a match win gets your team 20 extra
points so that's going to put them at a
staggering 58 points after the first
night ascension also winning both of
their matches not far behind with 54
points that's 14 board points plus 40
points for winning both their matches
edward jones did not field a full team
here tonight so the four board points
scored by uh alex kurford are all they
are walking away with bayer and doherty
both able to put up three points against
the strong enterprise and ascension
teams and then color art again also only
fielding a single player who did get two
points for their team to start off the
season
um so i had a lot of fun here hopefully
you guys enjoyed following along these
games with me uh if you did be sure to
tune in i think we're going to be back
here in another couple thursdays so not
next thursday but thursday march 10th i
believe we should be back unless it is
actually thursday march 3rd i could be
wrong on this maybe somebody in the chat
will help me out but just stay tuned for
more corporate chess league events i
love covering these games it's fun to
take a look at how um some players
slightly lower rated slightly lower
rated than myself play the game of chess
and i love giving my insights where i
can so huge thank you to all of you for
watching thank you to the players for
competing in the corporate chess league
i love these events always fun to uh to
meet up with these guys in person as
well i think we will be back in person a
little bit later in the season as well
which is going to be really really
exciting so stay tuned everybody thank
you so much for watching as always my
name is caleb denby and i will see you
next time
you